welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and the Joker has become the
central figure the DC Cinematic Universe
if there is such a thing anymore since
walking phoenixes Arthur Fleck Joker
appears to be in a universe all his own
and no one seems quite sure what is and
isn't canon from these films like I
think Superman is headless now
but while Joker and Batman are being
recast Margot Robbie's Harley Quinn is
one daring attempt by DC to keep alive a
well-liked element from the now ancient
history of 2016 by starring her in the
upcoming birds-of-prey film in February
2020 when we last saw her Lee Quinn in
the final scene of Suicide Squad she
appeared to be back in the embrace of
that Hong Kong Co Lee Jared Leto Joker
but now according to the new
birds-of-prey trailer that Joker is very
much out of the picture Joker and I
broke up so what happened asked are we
never getting any explanation in DC is
just pretending like many of us are that
Jared damage Leto Joker never happened I
don't think so
I think the Joker is going to be a very
important presence in Harley's world and
birds of prey beyond just that doodle on
a dartboard in fact if you paid close
enough attention to that trailer signs
of the Joker show up all over the place
and all of this evidence points to a
dark truth that Harley's Joker is
actually dead if this is true
DC is apparently going to conspiracy
level lengths to cover up this death in
the most insane way possible all to make
birds of prey yet another cathartic
emancipation that I would argue a number
of DC films have actually given us let
us break down this evidence for how DC
secretly murdered the Joker in this
episode of okay first let's start with
what the birds of prey trailer has told
us exactly harley narrates said she and
the Joker broke up she says that she
wanted a fresh start and she tearfully
cuts her pigtails with a blue and pink
hair dye that she got from diving into
the ace chemicals VAT in Suicide Squad
to prove her devotion to the Joker and
reminding us how a weirdly okay Gotham's
chemists are with leaving massive
uncovered vats and bubbling chemicals
under tended please somebody call OSHA
before another super villain gets formed
and if you look closely at the birds of
prey trailer there are shots of flaming
rubble which the final cast lists shot
Ruby
was hardly torching this same ace
chemicals facility and struttin away
like she's in a taste with music video
what thought about this is the Harley
from Suicide Squad would never let
herself go through this kind of breakup
like when the Joker tried to dump her
she chased him down on a goddamn
motorcycle wrecked it faced him down
like Kevin McAllister and shot a trucker
this ain't the girl you can break up
with she'll find you in in the birds of
prey footage Harley's behavior at times
directly contradicts this bold fresh
start for example among the many charms
she wears in her wardrobe is a fish hook
in the shape of a joker J very similar
to the angular shape of his J tattoo the
fish hook implies Harley is still hooked
on Joker's line she can't free herself
from his hookup polka also the young
Cassandra Cain has an arm cast with
graffiti drawn presumably by Harley
including each of the queens of a deck
of cards with each suit corresponding to
a different woman in the group but
Harley actually took this deck of cards
motif from her Joker on his neck was a
tattoo of the four aces again that Joker
lives on through Harley what we should
also acknowledge that every piece of
birds of prey promotion we've seen has
been highly deceptive the recent trailer
was clearly edited to soften adult
language with Harley's shirt pocket
conveniently masking over a word and
then an awkward cut to a reverse shot to
mask over what seems like one word but
probably ain't no one gives two shits
who we are and of course the teaser in
front of it chapter 2 used the gag of a
balloon pop to censor Harley clowns what
is Harley really over her clown part of
the deception of these promo clips has
been a deliberate smokescreen between
which shots show objective reality and
which are fantasy delusions inside
Harley's mind I have speculated past
episodes that Harley is becoming the DC
cinematics equivalent to Deadpool a
violent r-rated jokester who breaks the
fourth wall and uses humor to mask pain
and suffering like apparently when
Harley gets roughed up by black masks
gang he gets through the pain by
imagining herself in a dream sequence
omage to Marilyn Monroe singing diamonds
are a girl's best friend and Gentlemen
Prefer Blondes
so
Quinn is an unreliable narrator we
cannot trust what she tells us or what
we see through her eyes that includes
the words the Joker and I broke up but
I'm gonna explain the most mysterious
aspect of Harley Quinn and birds of prey
but before I continue thanks to our
sponsor Skillshare for helping us make
this episode Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes covering dozens of creative and
entrepreneurial skills explore classes
and everything from photography and
creative writing to marketing
productivity and more it's premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
high-quality classes from experts
working in their fields to help you gain
new skills and live your best life as a
screenwriter and film maker and
storyteller and general myself lately
I've actually gotten into documenting
all the new things that new rock stars
is going through and since I'm not much
of an editor I've really gotten a lot
out of the Skillshare course video
editing transforming footage into
evocative travel stories taught by
oliver astral Joe and since my hand gets
tired from journaling I feel like I'm
stitching together a documentary of my
BTS bill scher is also incredibly
affordable especially when compared to
pricey in-person classes and workshops
plus an annual subscription of
Skillshare is less than ten dollars a
month and because Skillshare sponsoring
this episode you will receive a two
month free trial just by clicking the
link in the description below just go to
skl sh / new rock stars 16 or click on
the link in the description ok I think
the most cryptic inconsistency with the
birds of prey trailer is the song choice
Edythe PS him na alum or if you know
your French which I don't had to look it
up this is a song of obsessive devotion
with lyrics referencing dyeing my hair
blonde and stealing fortunes just
because her lover tells her to the kinds
of things that Harley absolutely did for
Joker when they were still together but
very much at odds with what Harley says
she's feeling in birds of prey but to
find the true secret message of this
song so much gets illuminated when you
look at the history of YP f recorded it
we have dedicated this song to the love
of her life
French boxer Marcel Cerdan with whom she
had a short turbulent scandalous romance
since her Dan was an already married
father of three much like the kind of
short turbulent scandalous romance that
Joker and Harley @pf famously recorded
him a l'amour after surveying tragically
died in a plane crash to come see her
the song's legacy is that he loves
or a dead man in fact in the biopic of
Edith Piaf love Ian Rose with Marion
Cotillard this song is introduced with
the heartbreaking scene of PF learning
that sir Dan has died she first dreams
that he came home to her with a mourning
embrace but as she prepares his
breakfast she learns the truth from
others and she returns to her bedroom to
realize that he was never there she
dreamt it her man was dead if you think
about it it's pretty wild how similar
this could be to the last time we saw
Harley and her Joker together in Suicide
Squad in the final scene of that movie
Harley is alone in her prison cell
preparing breakfast and then boom a gang
and police tactical gear break her out
led by well it's Brennan on his suit
Luca Hongkou a man whom Harley assumed
died in a helicopter crash back in
Midway city but miraculously resurrected
without explanation here they embrace he
says let's go home before their faces
ignite in the neon and we jump into the
credits but doesn't this seem a bit nuts
Harley is locked in a maximum-security
prison as Amanda Waller said she locked
these criminals in hole and threw away
the hole whatever that means if the
Joker was this capable of busting her
out why does he wait until now and if
disguising himself and his gang and SWAT
gear was key to this infiltration and
breakout why does his SWAT gear have his
frickin name on it perhaps birds-of-prey
director Cathy and took a cue from the
song lyric that plays at the top of the
Suicide Squad scene the opening line of
Queen's Bohemian Rhapsody is this real
life is this just fantasy kind of a
landslide no escape from reality excuse
me I'm gonna go sing the rest of this
song and I'm back singing it I love it
okay this entire prison escape with
Harley and Joker could be as Queen
hinted just fantasy or a lover like PS
scandalous lovers sir Dan actually died
in an aviation accident this shock has
caught her in a landslide another lyric
that reflects PS mournful ode the blue
sky over us can collapse on itself and
the grounds can really cave in and to
cope with this tragic loss Harley Quinn
has fantasized an escape from reality or
as this movie's title suggests a
fantabulous emancipation and it's that
emancipation that will continue
throughout
to pray as she struggles to see her dead
ex-lover as a boyfriend she simply broke
up with a lie that's easier for her to
cope with that drawing of him on her
wall that she throws knives into already
has red X's over the eye in the mouth
she is knife being a corpse as if it
still needs to be killed her Joker is so
alive to her that she still even hears
his voice which if you were listening
closely the birds of prey trailer a
voice that seems to be that of black
mask actually sounds a bit like Jared
Leto you need me you need me you need
but that ex-boyfriend is a ghost
haunting Harley's fantabulous fantasy as
she struggles to live in a reality with
taste with style closure and a fresh
start
instead of the tragic truth that she
never got to say goodbye to the object
of her obsession in the DC Cinematic
Universe can use this death as a
convenient way to sweep into the rebel
of Midway City a Joker that fans aren't
too eager to see again and chalk up all
the canonical confusions of Suicide
Squad to be mere delusions of a damaged
mind a murder cover-up that we know is
actually do you think Harley's Joker
from Suicide Squad is dead or could he
still be alive comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at ei vas and to make episodes
of total conspiracy like this a regular
weekly thing on this channel and to help
us continue building up this temporary
setup to our aspirational venture new
rockstars digital studios with all kinds
of exciting new content for you guys
please please consider becoming a patron
and click the link to our patreon page
in the description below patrons will
get early access to content exclusive
premium breakdowns in more special
rewards just click that link in the
description below to our patreon page
for more details and thank you so much
to all of our current or past patrons
the ones who are super super generous
they deserve a special shout out look at
all these names I love all you guys
thank you for joining me and hey even if
DC didn't have this exact plan in mind
for the Leto Joker hey you know feel
free to use it
[Music]